there's something sad about everyone
moving right yeah
there's something sad about it it's sad
because of
how it happened you know what i mean
like
and like i said i'm i'm going to miss
the
comrade and again i got to give rogan
the credit for this he posted a picture
of his
studio i'm gonna i'm gonna miss the
community
right the there's such a collaborative
feel here
amongst comics yeah i'm gonna miss that
because a team
it really to me it helps the art
the collaboration and the more people
are together [ __ ] around
i think it makes people funnier and that
look at that that's like a spaceship
crazy it's cool huh that is bananas what
there's something uh i should probably
shouldn't say where that's at but
there's there's something
uh i think inspiring and
something like kind of like rebel-like
with everybody going out somewhere else
and starting fresh there
because comedy stories cement it's
always been so bad they didn't need you
know
other people but i think there's
something cool about that but then
there's something heartbreaking about
when i drive down laurel k and i'm like
huh ain't doing this again bubba
it's a it is a bummer that
this i mean the depends how you look at
it you know i
i think it'll be interesting to see
where the
next comedy hotspot will pop up i could
tell you
you think it's gonna be in austin i know
it is yeah
i mean it is the one thing that texas
has going for it
is obviously massive massive
and it's got the biggest comedian in the
world
coming there and he's bringing his
people so you know what i mean like
and there's something like really cool
about that yeah
it's like the regulators saddled up
mountain yeah
there's something really cool about it
you know yeah and then there's also
something that keeps me up at night
with horrible anxiety me too i mean i
mean i'm telling you i got
l.a tattoos all over me man i've i got
venice flowing through my veins and i
got
you know west hollywood you know no
sugar might think but yeah west
hollywood like
there's something to me with that i just
connect so much with like
the history of hollywood and the store
and like i think of
the laugh factory and like i just have
so many memories man
i but then there's out but then there's
that where it's
all about me and then there's stuff like
you know my sis my son growing up here
and i see the other kids in their pants
like that
that ain't good man that ain't real i
agree that ain't real i agree with all
these nannies that come up and pick up
these other kids this
i this ain't real man because i didn't
grow up like that and there's somewhere
if we go to texas i can be like that
yeah public school system they're some
of the best in the nation
if they are good at sports they have the
best football program in the nation
drew brees went to that school baker
mayfield went to that school
the academics are good so if they are
good at sports dude you're on the
highest level
possible but then i don't know there's
pros and cons man but it's
when i say it's probably the scariest
thing in my life man trying to figure it
out me too man you know
because the unknown is scary
but i but i what what does give me
comfort is if i know
my my closest friends coming with i know
my close friends are coming with me
joe's gonna be fine if nobody goes i
think he's doing joe's
joe yeah you know
joe rogan dude and i read an article
about a a
contract he just signed that i think
he's gonna be all right yeah so
yeah he could he could move tomorrow
and we're like okay yeah let's go
tomorrow but the funny thing is like are
you taking the
40-day trip to do rogan's podcast yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so there's that but i like there's
comfort in you know
i think if more people go you know like
me and theo talk about all the time
we so beth and i are also
we're we got one foot out it's for us
it's just
where and um do you have a few picked
out i have a few
when i don't narrow down to two oh you
went to two when i went to park city
this weekend not that i could live in
park city
but when i was on that ski lift going to
mountain biking i'm looking around like
this is living man my cousin it's a
little slow for it'd be slow for what i
do and be tough
my cousin was an actor scott scott has
worked since party of five oh wow salt
lake city
he loves it park well he they just moved
i'll do this move they just moved
chin have you been there probably just
stopped in real quick
the fish dude it looks amazing like i
was like holy [ __ ] when it's like
not every day yeah i dig it but then i
still have
some of that fast lane in my blood that
i need for stand-up and
just for stimulus to make the podcast
good like the vibe of l.a
because i don't know if that vibe is
going to be out there in texas dude then
that
worries me i keep telling back because
i'm around these hustlers and shakers
and
the vibe is like and you feel you got to
get up and you can feel it even though
i'm a little distance from it now where
i'm at you know my house now
but i drive in the city and you can just
feel this yes it's like you know when
all the bees vibrate and kill the big
hornet
like we're all a bunch of bees dude it's
why we moved from encino
we sold the house when the kids moved
out i'm like hey it's sleepy out here
let's get down where the energy is so
we're looking at two places man we're
looking at vegas
love it and we're looking at nashville
love it um
and it's but they're both scary
they're both br because we don't
know where our business is going to be
do you know what i mean so i can think
of all these places because i'd like to
travel a little less
so i'm trying to think what's where can
i work in town with a little bit of
hustle yep
and still drum up some business vegas
you'd get there
a hundred percent but when but when
yeah i know right the unknown is so
that's the thing
when if you were saying hey everything's
getting lifted tomorrow
would you go to vegas yeah because i
know that with some hustle
you can make you may but the people were
mentioned i think you're making it no
matter what
but i think it's to just to make sure
you're happy
the other thing i have to that on top of
my anxiety is i'm making a decision for
my two young kids and my wife my wife so
i have no friends out there
you'll find friends that's what beth's
saying we can find friends
yeah well i'm like you you be the only
friend you have now besides your family
who's gonna hear
my mother-in-law and follow on a
showdown they're like please we're ready
to go oh really they're coming with us
yeah so her friends but she her friends
now like she has friends from you know
she grew up with here but they see each
other sporadically but
her friends are from the mom group of my
kids friends well there's moms out there
yeah i'm sure they're dope i think i
have i have so
cause i went to college in texas i have
so many friends
and austin is a place that my wife and i
over the past two years
have hired real estate agents twice yeah
i mean we this isn't the
we we've been talking about leaving for
a while yeah i never have to we have i
thought i would
even if i moved outside my ass just
spread amongst to paying a candy or
laura king yeah
yeah it you there but you might not come
back that's what i'm saying yeah like
you sometimes get caught in your head
and you're like even if two years you're
like i just don't feel you can come back
yeah
no you can listen it's not saying and
truth of matter is
if you're asking me i think in two
a year two years would be a better time
to buy a house or rebuy a house or
whatever you're doing
than it is right now but nashville
i got a lot of friends you know he spent
a month out there and he's
he wants to bounce around so we're
banking all these kings thing and then
we have we have the whole schedule
mapped out so we don't miss any episodes
we bank episodes and then
if i go to texas we have episodes while
i'm moving so it's like
that's the thing the way we've set up
our business now
you don't have to live in the same city
no
you re what's he going to do
do you think he'll fly people in to
guest on his podcast he thinks there's
enough talent in nashville
for a while and then he'll fly people in
and then
you know but then we'll keep a studio
here in l.a then we'll both meet in l.a
do king his thing right then he'll be
able to bank couple of guest episodes
for his show
i'll have to flat here to film food
truck diaries unless the fighters are
out here
man she make it work yeah absolutely
we're going to make it work for sure
dude
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son